تشهد المملكة العربية السعودية تغييرًا كبيرًا، حيث
تنفق المملكة المليارات على
مشاريع هناك تهدف إلى وضعها
على الرادار العالمي وجلب بعض
الأسماء الكبيرة بالطبع، وقد وقع أحد تلك
الأسماء الكبيرة عقده في السعودية
بالأمس فقط نجم كرة القدم البرازيلي
وشكله.  الآن يوقع مهاجم باريس سان جيرمان نيمار جونيور
عقده الجديد مع
نادي كرة القدم السعودي، وإليكم أبرز ما في الأمر هو أن
الله حاليًا هو ثاني
أعلى منفق بين جميع
أندية كرة القدم المحترفة على مستوى العالم هذا العام وقد
سمعتموني جيدًا عالميًا متفوقًا على أمثال
باريس سان جيرمان مان يونايتد و  آرسنال ولكن
أين هي أعمدة المرمى هنا جيدًا في
ضوء هذه الانتقالات الضخمة،
تحدثت زميلتي إيلينا جوكو مع
الرئيس التنفيذي للعمليات في
الدوري السعودي للمحترفين للوصول إلى قاع
الممالك، أه فورة الإنفاق، استمع
إلينا، لقد فتحنا للتو  قناة جديدة
للاعبين لم تكن موجودة ولماذا
لا تكون في الشرق الأوسط لماذا
لا تكون في المملكة العربية السعودية لماذا يجب أن
تكون حصريًا في أوروبا
لذلك نحن نتحدى الوضع الراهن في
رأيهم ما نحن عليه.  نحن
نفعل شيئًا من أجل
المملكة العربية السعودية، نحن نفعل شيئًا من أجل
السكان المحليين وهذا
شيء
يجب على الجميع أن يشعروا بالارتياح تجاهه، أعني
لأننا مرتاحون جدًا لذلك،
لذا فإن الطرف الآخر من الطيف
الحجة هي أن هؤلاء
اللاعبين الكبار سيأتون إلى
المنطقة ولن
يواجهوا تحديًا حقيقيًا مع
الدوريات المحلية والفريق المحلي، ماذا
تقول لذلك في مواجهة تلك الحجة القائلة
بأنهم قادمون  هنا من أجل المال
في الوقت الحالي، كل ما يمكننا فعله هو وضع
المنتج، وكما ترون، فهو ليس
لاعبًا واحدًا، بل عدة لاعبين، وليس
ناديًا واحدًا، بل أندية متعددة، إنه
يرفع
المد الذي سيرفع جميع
السفن ولكنه
ليس كذلك  يكفي بالنسبة لي أن أخبركم
بهذه الأشياء، سيستغرق الأمر بعض
الوقت حتى يقتنع الجميع بأن
هذا هو المكان الذي نريد الذهاب إليه، وقد
مرت الدوريات الأخرى بنفس الشيء الذي
تعرفه يتبادر إلى ذهن MLS، لقد
استغرق الأمر سنوات عديدة و  لقد
تطورت مع مرور الوقت، وستكون هذه هي
نفس الرحلة تمامًا بالنسبة لنا، إلى متى
تعتقد أنها ستستغرق
وقتًا طويلاً، وقتًا طويلًا جدًا ولكن هذا
ليس مثل عقد، هل هذه خمس إلى عشر
سنوات، هل هي
أطول؟  من الممكن أن أقول إن فترة
خمس إلى عشر سنوات هي
الوقت الذي سيتم فيه
إعادة تقييم الأفق للاستراتيجية في ذلك الوقت ثم نرى كيف
نحتاج إلى تعديل المسار وتصحيحه لمواصلة
المضي قدمًا ولكن هذا ليس
شيئًا سيتوقف